bonjour je suis hespel est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du soul
is
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
et comme disait bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie tu ne seras avoué car la quête
du graal trouver la chaussure parfait en
chaume ou sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
gens aujourd'hui dans histoire de
souliers la marie jeanne
d'où vient-elle comment la portée des
professionnels de la mode de la
confection de chaussures vous
expliqueront son histoire saviez vous
par exemple que cette chaussure que l'on
rapproche aujourd'hui de l'escarpin et
de la sandale quitte à l'origine portée
par les hommes
vous découvrirez ensuite quelles sont
les tendances du moment
nos professionnels vous éclaire ont avec
leurs conseils shopping
ils vous apprendront également ce qu'il
faut éviter à tout prix
enfin nous vous présenterons des modèles
de marie-jeanne complètement extravagant
que vous n'avez probablement jamais vu
et qui ont fait fureur dans les milieux
de la haute couture et du design mais
tout apport à l'emploi ce que vous en
pensez
[Musique]
paris c'est au coeur de la capitale de
la mode que nous sommes allés enquêter
pour savoir ce que vous pensiez de la
marie jeanne
alors mesdames votre avis
en soirée
les baux talons
à aiguille avec une belle plateforme
devant ça fait classe
j'en ai déjà portée
sont vraiment que je suis très très
sensibles au style oui plutôt on était
tous lors de sorties aussi
ça c'est celui ci on a envie d'être
classe way
[Musique]
saviez vous que la mary jane était à
l'origine une chaussure exclusivement
masculine décidément le secteur de la
chaussure a connu des périodes des
changes des genres et des codes en
fonction des époques
un coup c'est et les femmes puis le
lendemain c'était les garçons la mary
jane et la version édulcorée de
l'escarpin la bride permet de passer
doucement d'une féminité naissante à une
nature bien plus affirmée penchons nous
sur l'histoire de la mary jane
[Musique]
qu'est ce que la mary jane ou la baby
vous évoque alors c'est un côté un peu
plus femme enfant c'est le confort et le
confort de comprendre la marche pour les
femmes qui ont des pieds faim et qui ont
tendance à sortir de la chaussure du
coup c'est une bride qui maintient les
pieds et puis c'est vrai que l'a
récemment on s'est bien amusé avec nos
maris gêne et on s'est fait donc des
nouvelles paires de chaussures qui
m'arrivait bientôt pour l'été où on a
mis de la couleur on a mis de la
paillette pour s'amuser un peu avec ses
brides qui du coup sont un peu moins
actuelle et casse un peu le côté hyper
sexy de l'escarpin donc c'est vrai que
la marie jeanne donne un côté un peu
plus femmes enfants donc je vais vous la
montrer en plus on laisse 48 heures que
j'adore avec l'affectionnent mon coeur
là on a une marie jeanne revisité donc
du coup c'est vrai que ça tire le pied
ça casse un peu le côté sexy comme l'a
dit juliette un peu de l'escarpin nu et
c'est tout coup de pieds nus là il
habille un peu en question confort est
question style c'est hyper sympa ça
revient énormément à la mode donc
vraiment à investir et à revisiter voile
avec des paillettes comme ici par
exemple ou avec du velours un peu flashy
et c'est d'accord donc si je n'ai pas
envie d'assumer l'escarpin pointu ultra
sexy voilà tu as tout compris est elle
tu rajoutes une marie jeanne ça te
donnera un côté un peu plus doux un peu
plus enfantin beaucoup moins femmes pour
voilà pour aller bosser tous les jours
etc
c'est hyper sympa est-ce que la mary
jane est encore à la mode
oui elle revient à la mode voilà et on a
beaucoup de demandes et on a beaucoup
beaucoup de demandes oui tu as raison
[Musique]
effectivement la mary jane reste
toujours un modèle incontournable
beaucoup de clientes et de personnes
portent la méridienne et la porteront
généralement la mary jane est porté par
des personnes un peu classique mais ça
commence mais effectivement il y a la
nouvelle tendance veut que maintenant
les personnes quand même des clients un
peu plus branché porte aussi la mary
jane sociaux la nouveauté cette année
c'est ce que j'appellerai mois la mary
jane décapotable
c'est à dire sans renfort à l'arrière et
très aérienne et trèbes il ajouté ça
fait partie de la famille des
parisiennes
mais mary jane habite aliens
[Musique]
la famille est issu d'une
réinterprétation de la chaussure
enfantine celle qui a assuré la
transition entre le stade du bébé à
celui de jeunes enfants qui commencent à
se déplacer mais bien avant le siècle
dernier la baby était une chaussure
essentiellement masculine
[Musique]
oh
en effet certains hommes de pouvoir de
la renaissance comme françois pommier ou
charles 9 ans portait sur certaines
peintures ou gravures de l'époque cela a
d'ailleurs valu l'autre appellation de
la baby elle est souvent appelée
l'acharnement
où
puis dès la fin du 19e siècle et jusqu'à
la moitié du 20e siècle
le jeune garçon portèrent les babines
comme dans les bandes dessinées de
basterds brad
mais dès les années 1930 ce sont les
actrices hollywoodiennes qui se sont
mises à la baby dans les années 1960 le
succès de la baby mary jane s'explique
en partie car ce soulier et fort de
symbole politique et sexuelle
[Musique]
il s'agit là d'un message d'innocence de
pureté et d'un retour aux sources
toutes ces valeurs étaient au coeur des
revendications les jeunes de la fin des
années 60 et 70
c'est à ce moment là que les créateurs
se sont emparés de ce sourire enfantin
c'est le début du style baby doll
chaussettes blanches tunique courte
tous les codes de l'enfant sont présents
mixer à une féminité naissante
et oui portait une baby est une étape
transitoire avant de se lancer dans le
port de l'escarpin à la sensualité
clairement affiché la mary jane s'est
adapté à merveille à la mode des années
60 très enfantine et régressive mais il
existe plusieurs versions sur le régime
de la baby certains experts s'accordent
à dire que la baby serait plutôt inspiré
de l'univers de la danse et de la
gymnastique
en effet on trouve des baby en toile et
gomme semblables à des chaussons de
danse on pratique d'ailleurs le flamenco
ou la danse de salon avec des mary jane
quelle que soit l'origine de la baby ou
de la mary jane il est certain que c'est
le soul et de la féminité aussi bien que
celui des danses traditionnelles
[Musique]
et ce qui me gêne est incontournable là
c'est une grande nuit
donc on le voit depuis 1910 tous les
années tous les années et c'est parce
que donc voici une mary jane détourné
c'est le modèle qui choses vraiment très
bien donc il y à cette bride au centre
nous on a fait courber mais c'est une
modèle ou avec les yeux fermés on sait
que la fille serait bien chaussé et elle
se rebelle
comment choisir son mary jane
morphologiquement là il ya moins de
contraintes donc on n'est pas du tout
dans une escarpins il y a des brides sur
une méridienne
il y à le cheville qui est tenu à une et
mieux chaussée dans une mairie jean
c'est clair et net
donc pour moi ça c'est une chaussure où
je peux vendre sept modèles à beaucoup
plus de clientes et c'est une chaussure
j'ai beaucoup plus de confiance le
vendre sur internet
je sais que ma cliente va être bien
chaussé dans une mary jane donc c'est
moins risqué cunin scarpe ans
que les maris jane's évoque alors la
mary jane ou du moins l'esprit
ils font que ça donne un côté un peu
plus habillée
parce que finalement cette bride qui au
départ va couper la cheville lui donne
un côté un peu plus habillée plus chic
plus élégant ça finit aussi un petit peu
le un petit peu le pied puis il ya
tellement de déclinaisons finalement
d'un arrêt jane c'est que à la fois on
peut avoir des modèles avec un compenser
intérieur plate forme avec quelques
choses franchement de très fort au
niveau du thil et puis on a parfois des
choses qui sont beaucoup plus simples
avec des petits bouts arrondis des
talents poussins avec des auteurs de 7
cm donc franchement on arrive à trouver
un petit peu tous les styles dans ce
genre de modèle c'est vraiment le modèle
passe partout par excellence qui peut à
la fois se mettre avec une jupe avec un
pantalon plutôt assez assez slim c'est
un modèle qui est assez facile et bon
suivant les saisons nous cette saison
dix ans qu'on en a un petit peu moins
mais on est déjà en train de travailler
sur l'été prochain et ça revient en
mayenne est toujours à la mode
finalement et puis voilà c'est un petit
peu comme escarpins ça s'en va et ça
revient
mais voilà c'est vrai que là c'est en
train de revenir un petit peu plus fort
parce que on voit dans les dents les
dans les carnets tendance quand même que
c'est une tendance qui est dans l'esprit
dans l'air du temps qui est peut-être un
petit peu plus discrète
donc ça revient ça revient fort aussi
[Musique]
la gamine mary jane ou charles neuf
trois appellations pour identifier une
chaussure fermée avec une bride autour
de la cheville
très bon chic bon genre dans sa version
plate elle rappelle l'univers de
l'enfance les socquettes blanches et les
jupes plissées
mais quand la mary jane ça bout d'un
joli talons elle devient la chaussure de
la féminité teinté d'un charme
délicieusement rétro elle donne
immédiatement envie d'enfiler une robe
vintage ou une jupe crayon la mode de la
chaussure je voulais que ça me plaît je
prends après je suis pas tellement ce
qu'il faut porter ou pas là moi je vous
avouerai que j'ai tout en fait j'ai un
peu de tout
en fait j'ai des copines très grand donc
quand chars avec eux mais des prix
l'emportent très rarement des talons
jamais jamais oh oui merci comment ça
marche à la tenue
ça dépend la fureur de m
il m'arrive parfois d'acheter une paire
de chaussures juste poursuivre avec ses
tenues la bouline qu'on va rester à des
chaussures que j'ai chez moi c'est comme
un jeu
c'est une manière de prolonger la partie
d'haïti
[Musique]
chaussures de femme enfant par
excellence la marie-jeanne aurait a
priori quelques difficultés à se trouver
une place dans le milieu de la haute
couture et du design qui généralement
conçoivent des tenues au caractère très
affirmé
et pourtant certains créateurs explore
ce côté petite fille le caractère
régressif de la marie jeanne et
parviennent comme toujours à nous
surprendre avec quelques idées hors du
commun référence ultime dans le domaine
de l'extravagance le controversé
alexander mcqueen affiche une
inspiration asiatique avec cette paire
de marie-jeanne dont la principale
originalité se situe dans la forme
incurvée du talon chez prada on retrouve
quelques modèles rebrodé de perles dans
les coloris assez inédit al'inverse
givenchy joue la carte de la sobriété et
l'originalité de ses modèles de
marie-jeanne réside essentiellement dans
l'abri du décoratives en métal
la maison chanel quant à elle se
réapproprie la marie-jeanne en y
incorporant des bétails emblématique de
la marque telles que l'association du
noir et du blanc ou encore le relief
matelassé du talon du côté de chez
louboutin
ce sont des modèles d'une hotte
délicatesse que l'on retrouve au trou
tueur avec résille pompons et plume
d'une part très échancré à paillettes
contrastant avec une bride unis d'autre
part ou encore toujours avec cette
inspiration aussi folle un modèle plus
rock avec des bris de multiples
plateformes incrusté de cloud et enfin
un modèle plus sobre jouant sur le
contraste des matières entre la bride et
la chaussure
toujours dans un esprit délicat mais
plus décoratif sert dur aussi propose
une bride qui habille la cheville à la
manière d'un bracelet et
d'impressionnantes ornementations
inspirées de la nature
la créatrice vivienne westwood opte
quant à elle pour l'accumulation de
brides et le talent de massifs pour des
formes originales en accord avec le
style extravagant qui caractérise la
marque sa collaboration avec mélissa
dans le domaine de la chaussure
enfantine qui avait également abouti à
la création de ballerines nous livre ici
un modèle de soirée avec bijoux dans la
même lignée la créatrice excentrique
betsey johnson ans présente un en
fourrure rose fuchsia et se mêlent
léocard
rien que ça
giuseppe zanotti de son côté est à
l'origine de ces modèles très design
sans talent et parfois entièrement
incrusté de strass
enfin kobi levi explore les opportunités
de la bride de la marie-jeanne dans le
style ludique et originale qui
caractérise sa marque modèle miao pour
ce petit animal à tête en forme de
pattes et modèles cheerleader pour ses
chaussures tricolore calqué sur les
tenues des pom pom girls
avec ces éléments imitant les pompons
les jupes à volants et même les
chaussettes
[Musique]
alors mon conseils pour bien choisir sa
marée j'aime voisin ici un escarpin
total au glitter avec une jolie marie
jeanne en glitter or donc du coup on a
une marie jeanne un peu revisitée donc
qui est au niveau de la cheville donc
vraiment la marie-jeanne ça vous permet
d'avoir un bon maintien du pied et en
même temps d'avoir un côté un peu plus
sobre que l'escarpin qui est nue où on
voit vraiment le coup de pied sahabi
vraiment la cheville et donc l'aspect du
pied c'est évidemment à accorder
lorsqu'on a un total look glitter assez
clinquant aux pieds avec une petite robe
noire ou encore un petit jean mais
vraiment quelque chose de sobre il faut
trancher mesdames
soit on choisit l'auditeur soit on
choisit le côté sobre
voilà pour accorder vraiment une tenue
qui ne va pas faire trop clinquante ou
trop vulgaire on peut aussi avoir une
marie jeanne qui est plutôt au niveau du
cou de pied
donc là on va avoir un aspect un peu
plus femmes enfants et là c'est vrai
qu'on peut se permettre pour le coup
d'avoir une tenue un peu plus sexy et un
peu plus flash
voilà ça donne tout de suite un côté
plus sobre au pied donc on peut vraiment
se lâcher en eau
voilà
or le conseil shopping sur la
marie-jeanne c'est pareil tête d'avoir
de très jolies jambes et avec une très
jolie jupe ou même un pantalon on le
pourra sans problème
on peut porter la de mary jane je pense
en toute saison donc plus jamais en
hiver et en automne et quand c'est l'été
un peu plus ouverte des formes un peu
plus estival mon conseil shopping sur
mary jane c'est de prendre des couleurs
inattendues
donc en fait de rompre le côté classique
tue mary jane avec des couleurs
surprenantes et de le porter avec des
robes
il est très belle porter avec une robe
une méridienne pour être tendance il est
intemporel
donc il est toujours tendance à ensuite
comment le choisir c est ce qu on veut
être sérieux donc il ya des modèles un
peu petite fille et il y à des modèles
donc là on est peut-être plus dans une
salle aux mails ou cette évocation du
nom salomé mais il ya des modèles très
sensuelle comme un coup porté une
méridienne pour moi toujours toujours
toujours avec une robe ou peut-être avec
son jean roulet
alors la mary jane l'avantagent déjà
c'est que vraiment c'est un modèle qui
passe partout donc c'est à dire qu'il
peut se mettre à la fois avec une petite
jupe qui soit au dessus du genou en
dessous un pantalon comme je disais ah
c'est slim donc vraiment c'est un modèle
finalement qui passe partout
moi ce que j'adore dans la mary jane
c'est vraiment le mélange de matières
j'adore le gouverner avec ensuite la
matière ou du moins le plus tôt le haut
de la chaussures en daim le talon en
daim ou en cuir mais voilà disons que le
mélange des matières donne un côté quand
même plus branché c'est vrai que
lorsqu'elle est unie elle a un côté
quand même un peu plus classique
donc nous on jouait vraiment à fond
cette carte là de mélanges de matières
de couleurs et ce qui fait qu'un modèle
parfois à l'air un petit peu plus
classique on arrive à le rendre beaucoup
plus pointu donc on aime bien ce mélange
de couleurs ça se porte
branges voilà moi je trouve que la tenue
idéale c'est une petite tenue un peu
courte
avec une petite veste à ces centres est
assez assez assez proche du corps donc
voila moi je trouve que voilà c'est la
tenue idéale c'est la mary jane bang
noir avec ce petit mix de matières et
voilà sorti avec une tenue extrêmement
simple moi ce serait mon corps mon
conseil serait donc récapitulons pour
être au top de la tendance avec vos
marie-jeanne mesdames aux et les
textures en tout genre
que vous soyez plutôt payet plutôt point
d'animaux ou les deux surtout ne vous
privez pas plus vous osez le mélange des
matières plus vous êtes branchés les
taux de strictes pour contrebalancer le
côté femme enfant de la marie jeanne la
tenue de femme sûre d'elle est la
bienvenue pour conclure la baby plate la
mary jane à talons ou encore la charles
neuf sont les trois termes différents
pour nommer cette fameuse chaussure
après avoir été masculine ce soulier est
entré dans la garde-robe défi lé la
chaussure phare du look baby doll à base
de broderies blanches et d'inspiration
rétro la baby ou la mary jane
s'accorderont facilement à tous les
styles
elle peut être portée aussi simplement
qu'un escarpins elle ira très facilement
avec un jean une robe ou un pantalon de
tailleur
si vous voulez jouer à 100%
l'inspiration rétro mixer vos mary jane
avec des pantalons à taille haute
des chemisiers imprimés vichy et un joli
rouge à lèvres vermillon la baby est une
chaussure que vous porterez quand vous
aurez envie de plaire ou d'avoir une
allure soignée
choisissez un modèle en cuir noir qui
vous suivra longtemps ou encore si vous
voulez être vraiment dans la tendance
actuelle
choisissez un modèle de mary jane très
original à pois ou à fleurs vos mary
jane décoré réveilleront à elle seule
une tenue sombre
à très bientôt pour la suite l'histoire
de souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]